in der Dämmerung des britischen
Weltreichs Bauten Banker Anwälte und
Buchhalter aus der Londoner City ein
Spinnennetz von offshore-geheimnissen
auf das Reichtum aus der ganzen Welt
einfing und nach London Schleuse
[Musik]
der britische Soldat
überall auf der Welt ist er zu finden
von Gibraltar bis Hongkong
überall steht dagegen die drohenden
Jahre standhaftes Symbol für unseren
gemeinsamen Willen Zuordnung Feuer
[Musik]
Großbritanniens zweites Empire
das britische Empire das größte Reich
das die Welt je gesehen hat über 300
Jahre lang herrschte Großbritannien
seine Armeen eroberten und seine
Bankiers verkündeten die Macht seiner
Währung
doch eines Tages begann alles zu
zerfallen ein Land nach dem anderen
erklärte seine Unabhängigkeit von
Großbritannien und keine noch so große
Kraft konnte den Lauf der Dinge
aufhalten als die britischen Eliten
sahen wie ihr Reichtum ihre Privilegien
und ihr Imperium zerfielen begannen sie
nach einer neuen Rolle in einer sich
verändernden Welt zu suchen und sie
fanden sie im Finanzwesen
[Musik]
dieser Film zeigt wie sich
Großbritannien von einer Kolonialmacht
zu einer modernen Finanzmacht wandelte
und wie dieser Wandel die Welt in der
wir leben geprägt hat
[Musik]
zu Zeiten des britischen Empire war die
City of London das größte globale
Finanzzentrum der Welt
die City of London war das pulsierende
finanzielle Herz des britischen Empires
die Historiker Kane und Hopkins nannten
sie den Regler des imperialen Motors all
diese Länder im Empire benutzen die
stirling-währung und die City of London
war sozusagen der Geldgeber nicht nur
innerhalb sondern auch außerhalb des
sterlingszone
ein Lastwagen der britischen Armee wird
bombardiert wobei zwei Soldaten getötet
und zwölf verwundet werden während sich
die Unruhen auf Zypern täglich ausweiten
beteiligen sich immer mehr Schüler an
der Gewalt hier wird eine Gruppe von
Mädchen nach einer steinwurfschlacht mit
der britischen Militärpolizei
auseinander getrieben
mit dem Niedergang des Empire waren die
britischen Handelsinteressen in aller
Welt bedroht
im Jahr 1956 verstaatlichte Ägypten den
Suezkanal
eine neue Krise im Nahen Osten beginnt
als der ägyptische Präsident na sehr
einer wildjubelnden Menge in Alexandria
mitteilt dass Ägypten den
internationalen Besitz befindlichen
Suezkanal beschlagnahmt hat
Frankreich und Großbritannien stellen
ein 12-stündiges Ultimatum innerhalb
weniger Stunden nach Ablauf des
Ultimatums fliegen britische
Kampfflugzeuge nach Ägypten und greifen
fünf wichtige Städte an darunter Kairo
die Vereinigten Staaten waren gegen die
Invasion und übten Druck auf
Großbritannien und Frankreich aus ihre
Truppen abzuziehen
es wird keine Beteiligung der
Vereinigten Staaten an dem gegenwärtigen
Feindseligkeiten geben es ist unsere
Hoffnung und Absicht dass diese
Angelegenheit vor die Generalversammlung
der Vereinten Nationen gebracht wird
dort kann die Meinung der Welt in
unserem Streben nach einem gerechten
Ende dieses quälenden Problems zur
Geltung gebracht werden
Großbritannien wurde gedemütigt die
Suezkrise bedeutete das Ende seiner
Rolle als eine der größten Mächte der
Welt
vollende crisis
nach der Krise gab es einen Ansturm auf
den Stirling des britische Pfund einige
Leute vermuteten dass die amerikanische
Regierung diesen Ansturm auf das Bund
förderte
Großbritannien abzogen Sankt der Wert
des Pfunds um seinen Wert zu schützen
schränkte Großbritannien die
Kreditvergabe der Banken im Ausland ein
sie waren nicht in der Lage im Ausland
zu investieren und offensichtlich waren
sie unglücklich wir kennen den genauen
Kontext nicht aber es ist sehr klar dass
die Banken oder ihrer Vertreter bei der
Bank of England vorstellig wurden die
ihrerseits vom Vertretern des
Bankensektors dominiert wurde
offenbar haben sie die Vereinbarung
getroffen die die schriftlich
festgehalten wurde dass wenn Banken
zwischen zwei nicht ansässigen
vermitteln in einer Fremdwährung in
diesem Fall dem Dollar dass die Bank of
England dieses Geschäft nicht als unter
ihre eigene Zuständigkeit fallend
betrachten würde beide
begannen einen Markt für Dollar in
London zu schaffen
Londoner Euro-Dollar market
um diese Aktivitäten von ihren
inländischen Bankgeschäften zu
unterscheiden führten die Banken zwei
verschiedene Konten
die Bank of England die britische
Aufsichtsbehörde erklärte dass sich die
Londoner euromarket konnten nicht in
London befänden sondern anderswo und
dass sie daher nicht für deren
Regulierung zuständig sei
es geht darum einen legalen Raum zu
schaffen indem man so tut als würde ein
Aktivität stattfinden und das wichtigste
daran ist dass man so tut als fände sie
nicht in der Wirtschaft statt in der sie
tatsächlich stattfindet man verlagert
also Aktivitäten von dem Ort an dem sie
reguliert und besteuert werden und tut
so als ob sie anderswo stattfinden
würden wo spielt eigentlich keine Rolle
es ist einfach woanders
als amerikanische Banken erkannten das
London die Möglichkeit Boot
US-Vorschriften zu umgehen verlagerten
sie ihre internationalen Geschäfte
dorthin
[Musik]
etwa zur gleichen Zeit als die
amerikanischen Banken ihre
internationalen Geschäfte nach London
verlegten begann eine andere neue Art
von finanzraum zu entstehen weit weg von
London in Großbritanniens
Überseegebieten den letzten Überresten
des Empire
in den 60er Jahren waren die
Cayman-Inseln ein totales Kaff man
erzählt sich dass es so viele Moskitos
in der Luft gab dass sie sogar Kühe
ersticken konnten das ist eine Legende
die man über die Cayman Inseln hörte ich
weiß nicht wie war sie ist aber es war
nichts los
Buchhalter und Anwälte aus London kamen
auf die Kaiman-Inseln und andere
britische Gebiete und begannen eine
Reihe von Gesetzen und Vorschriften zur
Wahrung des finanzgeheimnisses
auszuarbeiten da das wichtigste
Verkaufsargument dieser Rechtsordnungen
die Geheimhaltung war nannte man sie
geheimhaltungsrechtssysteme
was die Cayman-Inseln taten war schlicht
eine illegale Aktivität da kamen
Drogengeldern riesigen Mengen rein
Steuerhinterziehung was immer man wollte
man konnte es haben
die Bank auf England beobachtete die
Entwicklungen von London aus und
notierte in einem als geheim
gekennzeichneten Bericht vom 11 April 69
wir müssen ganz sicher sein dass die
mögliche Ausbreitung von
Treuhandgesellschaften Banken und so
weiter die in den meisten Fällen nicht
mehr als Messing Schilder wären die
Vermögenswerte außerhalb der Insel
manipulieren nicht außer Kontrolle gerät
es ist natürlich nichts dagegen
einzuwenden dass sie Schlupflöcher für
Gebietsfremde bieten aber wir müssen
sicher sein dass dadurch keine
Möglichkeit für den Transfer von
britischem Kapital in den nichts Darling
Raum außerhalb der britischen Regeln
geschaffen werden
[Musik]
diese kleine Territorien die letzten
Überbleibsel des britischen Empires die
immer noch Überseegebiete sind von
diesen Überseegebieten gibt es 14 7 von
ihnen sind gutgläubige Steueroasen
einschließlich der Cayman-Inseln der
Bermudas und der Britischen
Jungferninseln einige der größten
Steueroasen der Welt sind immer noch
britisch
[Musik]
mit dem Zugang zu großen Mengen an
offshorgeld wuchs der euromarket schnell
1980 hatte er 500 Milliarden Dollar
erreicht
1988 4,8 Billionen Dollar und 1997
wurden fast 90% aller internationalen
Kredite über diesen Markt vergeben
das britische Empire war untergegangen
Lied hatte kaum einer Spur hinterlassen
aber die City of landen passte sich an
und überlebte
Londons Finanzviertel ist ein besonderer
Ort
man nannte sie eine Stadt in der Stadt
einen Staat im Staat sie wird von einer
Organisation namens City of London
Corporation verwaltet einem privaten
Unternehmen das alle Funktionen einer
Stadtverwaltung mit einer privaten
Polizei und privaten Gerichten wahrnimmt
diejenigen unter Ihnen die nicht aus
Großbritannien kommen aber auch die die
es tun vielleicht sind sie sich nicht
bewusst was für ein seltsames Ding diese
kleine City of London innerhalb des
großen
die City of London ist eine vom größeren
London getrennte Einheit und hat ihr
eigenes Oberhaupt den Nordmeyer der sich
vom Bürgermeister unterscheidet der den
Rest von London regiert
[Musik]
jedes Jahr im November veranstaltet die
Stadt die Lord mayas-show den ältesten
Bürgerfest zu der Welt
[Musik]
London hat seit langem einen
merkwürdigen rechtlichen Status denn als
wilhelm der Eroberer 1066 kam war die
Stadt einer der wenigen Teile Englands
die er nicht der Opern konnte und der
Schloss 1067 einen Vertrag mit der Stadt
ab der es ihr erlaubte weiter zu
funktionieren bis heute ist die City of
London von vielen Gesetzen ausgenommen
die für das übrige Großbritannien gelten
ihr politisches System stammt noch aus
dem Mittelalter das grow der Wähler
machen nicht die Einwohner aus sondern
die in der Stadt tätigen
Privatunternehmen
der Oberbürgermeister wird von den
Oberhäuptern der mittelalterlichen
Zünfte gewählt
sie haben einen Vertreter im Unterhaus
den rememberance abgesehen von den
gerichtsschreibern ist er die einzige
nicht gewählte Person im Unterhaus
alle anderen Lobbyisten müssen in der
Lobby anhalten sie dürfen die Lobby
nicht passieren die City of London hat
einen ständigen Vertreter im Unterhaus
dessen Aufgabe es ist der City of London
Corporation Bericht zu erstatten und im
Namen der Stadt Lobbyarbeit im Parlament
zu betreiben
Corporation of London ist ein
einzigartiges und interessantes Phänomen
das viele Politikwissenschaftler
politische Ökonomen und
Wirtschaftswissenschaftlern gezogen hat
ist
aber ich kenne niemanden der die
Corporation of London und ihren Einfluss
auf die Politik oder die
Wirtschaftspolitik systematisch
untersucht hat
wir können also nur vermuten dass die
Corporation of London extrem mächtig und
in der Lage ist die britische Politik
auf die eine oder andere Weise zu
gestalten vor allem bei den
finanzmethoden Artikel wird ihn
vielleicht
der Premierminister nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg hatte etwas über die City of
London Corporation zu sagen
wir haben immer wieder gesehen dass es
in diesem Land eine andere Macht gibt
als die die ihren Sitz in Westminster
hat die City of London ein passender
Begriff für eine Ansammlung von
Finanzinteressen ist in der Lage sich
gegen die Regierung des Landes
durchzusetzen diejenigen die das Geld
kontrollieren können im Innen und
Ausland eine Politik betreiben die im
Gegensatz zu der steht die vom Volk
beschlossen wurde
im Herzen der City of London steht die
Bank of England die Bank of England ist
nicht nur eine Zentralbank sie ist auch
eine Finanzaufsichtsbehörde beim
Untergang des Empire nutzte die Bank of
England diese regulierungsbefugnis um
die Banken der Welt nach London zu holen
im Jahr 1972 erteilte die Bank of
England der Bank of credit entcommercial
international die ihren Hauptsitz in
London einrichtete eine Lizenz
innerhalb von 10 Jahren wuchs die BCCI
zur 7 größten Bank der Welt heran zehn
Jahre später war sie bankrot Bank
der stellvertretende Direktor des CIA
Richard kill sagte heute dass die CIA
dbci zu Unterstützung von CIA
Aktivitäten in Übersee genutzt hat
aber wie sie sie hat nicht nur mit dem
Geheimdiensten der Welt
zusammengearbeitet sondern war auch ein
umfangreichen Finanzbetrüger rein
Geldwäscherei und Terrorismus
Finanzierung beteiligt
dieses Jahr die BCCI beging
internationale globale Verbrechen von
einem Ausmaß das einem den Verstand
raubt die BCCI finanzierte den
Terrorismus die Bank of England wusste
das sagt der Bericht aber anstatt sie
richtig zu überwachen versuchte sie den
Zusammenbruch der Bank zu verhindern
ich sage ganz direkt dass die Bank of
England genügend Informationen hatte um
BCCI 15 Monate früher zu schließen als
sie es getan hat und Millionen von
Kontoinhabern wurden dabei geschädigt
zahlreiche Whistleblower von BCCI hatten
sich an die Bank of England doch die
Bank of England unternahm nichts
auf time die Bank of England hatte
reichlich Zeit einzugreifen und
Nachforschungen anzustellen aber sie hat
es nicht getan denn die Tradition war
und ist auch heute noch dass man sich
Hinweise gibt und dann mit den Jungs die
die anderen Jungs kontrollieren am
Mittagstisch kurz drüber quatscht und
dann würde schon alles gut werden
der Gouverneur der Bank of England zum
Zeitpunkt des Zusammenbruchs von BCCI
sagte dass derzeitige Aufsichtssystem
hat der Gemeinschaft gute Dienste
geleistet wenn wir jedes Mal eine
bankschließen würden wenn wir einen
betrugsverlauf haben
London war für die Banken ein Ort an dem
sie Geschäfte machen konnten die
anderswo nicht erlaubt waren und an dem
sich die leitenden Bankangestellten
keine Gedanken über die Konsequenzen
ihres Handelns machen mussten dies ist
einer der Gründe warum es heute in
London mehr Banken gibt als an jedem
anderen Finanzplatz
in Großbritannien kommt niemand ins
Gefängnis Banker kommen nicht ins
Gefängnis sie sind eine geschützte
Spezies und das ist Teil des
offshore-geschäftsmodells des
Vereinigten Königreichs nämlich zu sagen
wir werden euch beschützen wir bringen
euer Geld hierher wir kümmern uns um
euch verstecken euch nicht ins Gefängnis
wir lassen euch tun was ihr wollt
eine sanfte Regulierung war eine
Möglichkeit um Unternehmen nach London
zu locken eine andere war die
Geheimhaltung ab den 60er Jahren
begannen die Institutionen der City of
London offshore Niederlassungen in
ehemaligen Außenposten des britischen
Empire zu errichten ihr Ziel war es
offshorezentren mit strengen
Geheimhaltungsvorschriften zu schaffen
um Kapital aus der ganzen Welt
anzuziehen
[Musik]
ist das bekannteste sie legen ihr Geld
bei einer Schweizer Bank an und
versprechen es niemandem zu sagen das
ist eine Art der Geheimhaltung aber eine
andere Art der Geheimhaltung die sehr
britische ist ist die Treuhand und die
Treuhand ist ein sehr schlüpfriger
komplizierter und hinterhältiger
Mechanismus
Trust im die Legenden über die Treuhand
stammen aus der Zeit der Kreuzzüge als
die Ritter in fremde Länder zogen um zu
kämpfen und ihr Vermögen in der Obhut
vertrauenswürdiger Verwalter ließen
was Treuhandgesellschaften letztendlich
tun ist sie spielen mit dem Konzept des
Eigentums Eigentum ist keine so einfache
Sache der Treugeber in diesem Fall der
Ritter übergibt das Vermögen an jemanden
der heutzutage Treuhänder genannt wird
oft ein Anwalt rechtlich gesehen sind
sie von diesen Vermögenswerten getrennt
sie gehören nicht ihnen es gibt eine
Schranke sie können dafür nicht
besteuert werden niemand wird etwas über
ihre Verbindung zu diesen
Vermögenswerten herausfinden in den
britischen offshore Rechtssystemen sind
keine Qualifikationen erforderlich und
Treuhänder zu sein jeder kann einen
Trust gründen und als Treuhänder
fungieren es gibt keine Register keine
stellen die bescheinigen dass eine
Treuhandgesellschaft gegründet wurde
[Musik]
die einzigen Personen die von der
Errichtung dieser Vereinbarung wissen
sind der Treuhänder und der Treugeber es
gibt keine Verpflichtung sie zu
registrieren es gibt keine Verpflichtung
zur Finanzberichterstattung für Trusts
sie sind nicht verpflichtet irgendwo
Jahresabschlüsse zu hinterlegen Trust
sind also in jeder Hinsicht unsichtbare
Vereinbarungen
der Wirtschaftswissenschaftler John
Kristen sind war zehn Jahre lang
Wirtschaftsberater für das
geheimhaltungsrechtssystem von Jersey
wir reden hier nicht über ein paar
Millionen wir sprechen über Billionen
Billionen von Dollar an Kapital die
scheinbar niemandem gehören weder für
Steuerzwecke noch für andere Zwecke die
gehören niemandem alles Kunstwerke
Goldbarren Rennpferde Autos Immobilien
nicht nur finanzielle Vermögenswerte
sondern auch eine ganze Reihe nicht
finanzieller gehören diesen trust
denken Sie einmal darüber nach denn wir
sprechen hier von 50 Billionen Dollar an
Vermögenswerten die sich hinter diesem
Apparat
verbergeninseln sind eines von mehreren
britischen Überseegebieten die ein neues
Abkommen zum Informationsaustausch mit
Großbritannien und dem Rest Europas
unterzeichnet haben um
Steuerhinterziehung zu bekämpfen die
Länder müssen nun automatisch
Einzelheiten über Bankkonten und deren
Verwendung übermitteln kein Mann wurde
letzte Woche zum ersten Unterzeichner es
ist wichtig dass die Cayman-Inseln als
erstes Überseegebiet anerkannt werden
dass ein solches Abkommen mit dem
Vereinigten Königreich unterzeichnet hat
und ich denke die spiegelt den
konstruktiven Ansatz wieder den die
Cayman-Inseln bei der Verwirklichung
unseres gemeinsamen Ziels die
Steuerhinterziehung auszurotten verfolgt
haben
[Musik]
ist der Kern des britischen
geheimhaltungsmodells sie haben kein
Banken Geheimnis das haben die Schweizer
die Briten sind natürlich nur zu gerne
bereit das bankengeheimnis abzuschaffen
weil sie dann einen größeren
Marktanteile erobern könnten das ist der
Grund warum sie das tun
sind der Grundbaustein des
angelsächsischen Bankgeheimnisses und
sie bilden die Basis auf der komplexe
offshorststrukturen entstehen jedes
geheimhaltungsrechtssystem bietet eine
Reihe von Dienstleistungen an von Trusts
über Briefkastenfirmen bis hin zu
geheimen Bankkonten und benannten
Direktoren die Kombination dieser
Dienstleistungen in komplexen Strukturen
die sich über mehrere Rechtssysteme
erstrecken ermöglicht die Schaffung von
geheimhaltungsstrukturen die fast
unmöglich zu durchdringen sind
eine offshorestruktur wird von einem
Treuhandfond überlagert die
Treuhandgesellschaft verwaltet das
Vermögen und kontrolliert das
gewissermaßen darunter besitzt die
Treuhandgesellschaft einige
mantelgesellschaften sind die jeweils in
einem anderen Rechtssystem angesiedelt
sein können sie könnten also eine
Treuhandgesellschaft in einem Land haben
deren Treuhänder an einem anderen Land
sind deren begünstigte in einem anderen
Land sind die wiederum
Offshore-Gesellschaften in einem anderen
Land besitzt und jede dieser
Gesellschaft könnte dann Vermögenswerte
besitzen sie könnten ein Bankkonto ein
Rennpferd eine Yacht ein Gemälde ein
Aktienportfolio oder was auch immer
besitzen
es gibt viele Varianten von Trusts und
offshore geheimnisstrukturen es gibt
offshoreanwälte deren Arbeiterin besteht
immer komplexere und undurchsichtigere
Strukturen zu schaffen das Ziel dieser
Strukturen ist es die Identität der
Eigentümer von offshorevermögenswerten
zu verbergen und es zu ermöglichen das
offshorevermögen wieder in die globalen
Märkte zurückfließt
wenn man sich die Menge an Geld an Sie
die von Steueroasen aus verwaltet wird
sieht man dass es eine Kurve ist die so
verläuft und all die Gespräche die wir
geführt haben mit anderen wunderbaren
Menschen die gegen Steueroasen kämpfen
haben nichts geändert es ist eine Welt
in der man immer weiter redet und immer
weiter redet ja interessant aber ich
werde weiter tun was ich tun will wir
wissen heute alles denn wir hatten die
Panama papers wir haben sie gesehen
und wir sind nicht in der Lage darauf zu
reagieren weil dieses System wirklich
die wenigen Leute schützen die davon
profitieren
und das sind prozentual gesehen nur sehr
wenige Menschen aber sie sind mächtig
und ich sehe im panama-ausschuss in dem
ich sitze das einzige was dies ändern
könnte
wäre ein öffentlich zugängliches
Register des wirtschaftlichen Eigentums
der Trust und aller möglichen
Unternehmen
ganz einfach
[Musik]
sind zugespielte Dokumente der
offshore-kanzlei mossack von ca mossack
von Seka ist die viertgrößte auf
schorkanzler die anderen neuen der zehn
größten auf schaukanzleien sind in
britischen Überseegebieten registriert
wenn sich Länder in Großbritannien über
die Aktivitäten beschweren die von
seinen offshore-paradiesen aus betrieben
werden behauptet Großbritannien dass
diese Orte unabhängig sind und das ist
nichts tun kann
ich aber immer wieder von Beamten in
Berlin und in Paris und in Washington
und den anderen Ländern gehört dass die
britische Regierung ihnen gesagt hat ja
sie wissen sehr wohl was in Jersey vor
sich geht und sie halten es für sehr
bedauerlich aber sie haben nicht die
Befugnis einzugreifen
nun das ist eine glatte Lüge sie haben
die Befugnis einzugreifen nur Sie
entscheiden es nicht zu tun
Großbritannien spielt diese Art von
Spielen in dem es so tut als ob diese
Orte unabhängig wären wenn es ihnen
passt letzten Endes einen Großbritannien
denn Gouverneur er nennt viele
hochrangige Leute in diesen Ländern ist
für die Außenbeziehungen und die
Verteidigung verantwortlich und kann
auch ein Veto gegen deren Gesetze
einlegen Großbritannien hat also ein
hohes Maß an Kontrolle im Grunde
kontrolliert es diese Orte und lässt
Ihnen nur wenig politischen Spielraum
während seiner Zeit als
Wirtschaftsberater von Jersey reiste
John Christensen häufig nach London zu
Gesprächen mit verschiedenen britischen
Regierungsstellen
als Wirtschaftsberater hatte ich viel
Kontakt mit verschiedenen Ministerien
traditionell haben die britischen
Regierungen versucht sich nicht in die
inneren Angelegenheiten von Orten wie
Jersey einzumischen es geschieht also
auf eine eher subtile Art und Weise man
geht zu jemandem im Innenministerium
oder im Finanzministerium und er sagt
wir sind eigentlich nicht besonders
scharf auf dieses Gesetz es wäre
vielleicht eine gute Idee wenn Sie
diesen Weg nicht einschlagen würden und
bei einer Tasse Tee ist das ein ziemlich
starkes Signal das Signal geht zurück
auf die Inseln und sagt dass sie nicht
wollen dass sie das macht
die britische Regierung zieht es vor
sich nicht offen einzumischen sondern
teilt ihre Wünsche durch informelle
Gespräche mit
es gibt keine Papiere oder eine
offizielle Erklärung die Diskussionen
finden hinter verschlossenen Türen statt
die Beziehung zwischen diesen Orten und
London hat viel mit dem britischen
establishmen zu tun und damit dass man
sich gegenseitig versteht
jeder der Brite ist oder die Briten
kennt weiß dass die Kommunikation
zwischen uns oft sehr subtil ist und man
die Codes kennen muss wenn die Leute
etwas sagen es ist viel Ironie im Spiel
und eine Menge kodifizierter Sprache ähm
keine language man muss verstehen wie es
funktioniert
und ich glaube das ist bei den
britischen Beziehungen zu den
Steuerparadiesen sehr stark der Fall ich
glaube es gibt ein großes Verständnis
dafür was wir tun können und was nicht
ohne dass man es wirklich aussprechen
muss in dem Großbritannien seine Macht
verborgen hält kann es behaupten dass
diese Länder politisch autonom sind
Unabhängigkeit für die kann man Inseln
steht nicht auf der Agenda der Regierung
diese Botschaft wird an den
un-sonderausschuss zur
Entkolonialisierung geschickt der Anwalt
Steve mcfield wird die Regierung bei dem
Treffen vertreten das Komitee Kolonien
auf der ganzen Welt auf dem Weg in die
Unabhängigkeit begleiten aber mcfield
sagt kein Mann sei nicht bereit für
diesen Übergang
Mandat Messgerät ist da und die
Botschaft ist dass der Premier dieses
Kabinett diese Partei kein Mandat von
der Bevölkerung der Cayman-Inseln hat
die Unabhängigkeit anzustreben diese
Botschaft werde ich überbringen
als die Bahamas 1967 ihre Unabhängigkeit
von Großbritannien erklärten verlegten
die offshore Banker ihren Sitz auf die
Kaimaninseln und setzten von dort aus
ihre Geschäfte fort es war die britische
Verbindung die den Bankern und ihren
Kunden die Gewissheit gab dass Ihr Geld
sicher war
this britisch dieses britische Fundament
hat es diesen Ordner ermöglicht das
Vertrauen der
Finanzdienstleistungsbranche und der
Ortschaft Finanzbranche und all dieser
Leute zu gewinnen
in Wirklichkeit wird ein Großteil des
Vermögens das in den offshore-oasen
verwaltet wird von London aus
kontrolliert
die City of London erledigt ihre
schmutzige Arbeit im Großen und Ganzen
gerne außerhalb Londons es könnte Gott
bewahre eine Aufsichtsbehörde geben die
die Arbeit ernst nimmt und sehen London
wegen Betrugs verfolgt es ist also
besser die Betrügereien offshore in
Gibraltar oder Jersey zu machen wo das
Risiko einer ernsthaften Strafverfolgung
viel geringer ist
die Geschäfte werden oft in London
besprochen und abgeschlossen dann aber
aus steuerlichen und regulatorischen
Gründen im Ausland registriert
in schmutzige Geschäfte verwickelt zu
werden aber wenn das Skandal zuschlägt
sagen sie also die sind unabhängig wir
können nichts gegen diese Unternehmen
tun das sind nicht wir das sind
Aktivitäten in Steueroasen und wir sind
die Stadt wir haben mit solchen Dingen
nicht zu tun es ist also eine
unglaublich bequeme Beziehung
[Musik]
City of London hat die Art und Weise
geprägt wie sich Jersey
und die britischen Überseegebiete als
Steueroasen entwickelt haben ich sehe
diese Orte als die Frankensteins die von
der City of London geschaffen worden
beide
heute ist das Vereinigte Königreich der
weltweit größte Anbieter von
internationalen Finanzdienstleistungen
das Vereinigte Königreich hat eine fast
einzigartige Rolle im globalen
Finanzwesen wenn man sich die Daten
ansieht wie Art von Daten die wir im
finanzgeheimnis-index erstellt haben
kann man die relativen Anteile der
einzelnen Länder an der weltweiten
Bereitstellung von
Finanzdienstleistungen für nicht
ortsansässige sehen es gibt zwei große
Zentren und alles andere ist im
Vergleich dazu ziemlich
Kleinigkeiten die beiden großen Zentren
sind die Vereinigten Staaten mit etwa
19% des Weltmarktes und das Vereinigte
Königreich und seine offshore
rechts-systeme die etwa 25% des
Weltmarktes ausmachen
und wenn man dazu noch andere
Rechtssysteme hinzurechnen hat ehemalige
Kolonie die aber erst kürzlich
unabhängig wurden Hongkong Singapur
vielleicht sogar Dubai Bahrain und
Zypern dann kommt man auf eine Zahl von
fast 40
%. ich glaube das diese Zahl die
Position Londons auf dem globalen
Finanzmarkt besser wiedergibt
die Soldaten gingen die Verwalter
verließen alle Kolonien aber sie
behielten immer noch eine erhebliches
Maß an Kontrolle über die Finanzströme
aus diesen ehemaligen Teilen des
Imperiums und dem Rest der Welt man
könnte es also als ein zweites Imperium
bezeichnen Großbritannien zweites
Imperium ein verstecktes Finanzimperium
das sich über weite Teile des Globus
erstreckt
zur Zeit des britischen Empire war die
City of London das größte globaler
Finanzzentrum der Welt
nicht nur die britischen Kolonien
sondern auch unabhängige Länder
wickelten ihre Bankgeschäfte in London
ab und nutzten die Währung des Empire
für Handel und Finanzierung
mit dem Niedergang des Empire ging auch
die City of landen unter
die Einrichtung des Londoner Euro market
ermöglichte es den Banken der City of
London ihre Netzwerke und ihr Fachwissen
aus der Zeit des Empire weiter zu nutzen
und die Schaffung von
geheimhaltungszonen verschaffte den
Banken Zugang zu großen Mengen billigen
Geld ist internationale Banken aus der
ganzen Welt gründeten Niederlassungen in
London und in den britischen
offshorländern um von diesem neuen
System zu profitieren
dieses System hat den Platz der
Besatzung eingenommen
in Frankreich war es bis 1962 so in
England weiß ich es nicht aber ungefähr
zur gleichen Zeit war England zum
Beispiel in Indien oder in anderen
Kolonien physisch präsent und wenn man
sich die Geldströme durch die
Steuerparadiese ansieht dann nehmen Sie
zu wenn wir uns aus den Kolonien
zurückziehen wir plündern als ehemalige
Kolonialmächte immer noch die
Entwicklungsländer
wohlhabende Einzelpersonen das
organisierte Verbrechen und Unternehmen
verlagerten ihren Reichtum ins Ausland
im Austausch für Geheimhaltung und
Steuerfreiheit und als Länder aus der
ganzen Welt begannen ihre
Volkswirtschaften zu deregulieren und zu
öffnen wurde es immer einfacher dies zu
tun heute könnte die Hälfte des
weltweiten offshorvermögens in
Großbritanniens geheimen Rechtssystemen
versteckt sein
einer der Verlierer ist Afrika dessen
fluchtkapital hauptsächlich in das
moderne britische Spinnennetz fließt
ich glaube es ist kein Zufall dass
Großbritanniens offshore Imperium mehr
oder weniger zur gleichen Zeit entstand
wieder Zusammenbruch des
forellenimperiums
wir neigen dazu uns Afrika als einen
riesigen nettoschuldner gegenüber dem
Rest der Welt vorzustellen aber das hier
war das Ausmaß ihrer Schulden Ende 2008
177 Milliarden Dollar
die Schulden der afrikanischen Länder
südlich der Sahara beliefen sich 2008
auf 177 Milliarden Dollar doch der
Reichtum den die Eliten dieser Länder
zwischen 1970 und 2008 ins Ausland
verschoben wird auf 944 Milliarden
Dollar geschätzt mehr als das Fünffache
944 Milliarden Dollar rechnen Sie mal
nach Afrika ist weit davon entfernt ein
nettoschuldner zu sein Afrika südlich
der Sahara ist ein Netto Gläubiger für
den Rest der Welt
als das Kapital ins Ausland abwanderte
lehnen sich die afrikanischen Staaten
Geld von internationalen Banken zu hohen
Zinsen mit der Zeit wurden diese
Schulden so hoch dass sie möglicherweise
nie zurückgezahlt werden können
die geheime Rechtssprechung brachte die
Entwicklungsländer um ihren Reichtum und
ihre Steuereinnahmen
seit langem versuchen viele
Entwicklungsländer darunter seit kurzem
auch Ecuador ein un-steuergremium
einzurichten das einen höheren Standard
hat als das derzeitige un-steuergremium
und jedes Mal wenn das passierte wurde
es blockiert während des Prozesses der
Entwicklungsfinanzierung in Addis Abeba
im letzten Jahr waren es glaube ich das
Vereinigte Königreich und die USA die
erneut versuche zu Einrichtung dieser
Welt steuerorganisation blockierten
warum wollen Sie keine demokratische
Entscheidungsfindung bei globalen
Entscheidungen darüber wie Steuern
grenzüberschreitend erhoben werden ich
verstehe das nicht solange wir
grenzüberschreitende Aktivitäten haben
die sowohl kriminelle als auch legale
Aktivitäten beinhalten solange wir nicht
in der Lage sind diese beiden zu trennen
wird dies weiterhin ein Problem sein
die westlichen Länder blockieren
Versuche für mehr Transparenz bei den
internationalen Finanzströmen zu sorgen
und globale Standards für die
grenzüberschreitende Steuererhebung
einzuführen während die Eliten in den
Entwicklungsländern off shorezentren
nutzen um ihren Reichtum im Ausland zu
verstecken
das Öl in Carbon ist den Menschen in
Gabun nicht zu Gute gekommen das gilt
auch für das Kupfer in Sambia und für
das Gold in Mosambik oder in Mali
die Unternehmen die es fördern und ihre
Aktionäre haben davon profitiert die
korrupte Elite des Landes hat davon
profitiert
Paradise die Ausplünderung dieser Länder
durch ihre Eliten erleichtert es hat
ihnen ermöglicht das Geld zu stehlen und
es irgendwann an der sicher
aufzubewahren
unerlaubte Finanzströme weil die
Anonymität die ihnen zugrunde liegt
Anreize für Menschen in Machtpositionen
schafft korrupt zu sein das ist der
Grund warum es eine Gruppe von Ländern
gibt in denen Entwicklungsfortschritte
so schwierig sind das liegt daran dass
die Anreize für Einzelpersonen und die
Möglichkeiten sie durch all die
Mechanismen zu verfolgen die illegalen
Finanzströmen zugrunde liegen schwerer
wiegen als die Art von Mechanismen die
zu einem mächtigen repräsentativen
effektiven Staat führen der die
Entwicklung in Gang bringen kann
[Musik]
weltweit verlieren die
Entwicklungsländer jedes Jahr über eine
Billion Dollar durch Kapitalflucht und
Steuerhinterziehung der größte Teil
dieses Reichtums fließt in große
westliche Länder wie die Vereinigten
Staaten und Großbritannien und
ermöglicht es deren Währungen stark zu
bleiben während die Währungen der
Entwicklungsländer schwach bleiben aber
die illegalen Ströme in die westlichen
Länder hatten noch einen weiteren
unerwarteten Nebeneffekt in den
Volkswirtschaften der Vereinigten
Staaten und Großbritanniens begann eine
Finanzialisierung die Ursprünge dieses
Finanzmarktkapitalismus oder der
Deindustrialisierung reichen bis in die
60er Jahre zurück
die kriegsdemonstranten protestieren
gegen die Beteiligung der USA haben
Vietnamkrieg in massenmärschen
Kundgebungen und Demonstrationen
Präsident Johnson lauten dass das FBI
alle an die kriegsaktivitäten genau
beobachtet in den 60er Jahren arbeitete
der
us-wirtschaftswissenschaftler Michael
Hudson bei der Chase Manh Gelenk an der
Wall Street als Experte für die
Zahlungsbilanz
in den 60er Jahren war das
zahlungsbilanzdefizit der Vereinigten
Staaten ausschließlich auf ausländische
Militärausgaben zurückzuführen
aufgrund der Kosten des Vietnamkrieges
flossen Dollars aus den Vereinigten
Staaten ab die USA versuchten zu
verhindern dass die Dollars die nach
Vietnam flossen auf ausländischen Banken
deponiert wurden
die Regierung war Chase während des
Vietnamkrieg seine Filiale in Saigon
einzurichten wie Sie sich vorstellen
können gab es dort keine Fenster es war
eine Art Festung und sie verlor Geld
aber die Regierung ging zu Chase und
sagte wenn Sie dieses Geld das vom
militären Vietnam abgeworfen wird nicht
kriegen dann wird es in französische
Banken fließen es wird zu general de
Gaul gelangen und sie wissen was er dann
damit tun wird er wird es gegen Gold
eintauschen das ist das was die USA zu
verhindern
da es den USA nicht gelang den
Geldabfluss zu stoppen begannen sie
einen anderen Plan auszuhecken
1967 bekam Michael Hudson von einem
ehemaligen Mitarbeiter des
Außenministeriums ein Memo in die Hand
gedrückt denn 19667
gab mir ein ehemaliger Mitarbeiter des
Außenministeriums im Aufzug von Chase
Manhattan ein Memo in dem darauf
gedrängt wurde dass Chase Manhattan die
Führung dabei übernehmen solle den
Vereinigten Staaten dabei zu helfen die
Schweiz der Welt zu werden
das heißt die Schweiz für fluchtkapital
das Außenministerium forderte mich auf
zu schätzen wie viel Geld meiner Meinung
nach zur Verfügung steht wenn Amerika
die neue Schweiz werden würde und wie
wir das anstellen könnten der Plan war
offshore bankzentren in der Karibik und
anderswood organisieren und dass das
heiße Geld nicht direkt zu Chase kommen
würde weil das nicht schön und legal
wäre nice was passiert der war dass die
lateinamerikanischen Kriminellen und
andere kriminelle Drogenhändler alle
Arten des organisierten Verbrechens ihr
Geld in die offshoreanten in der Karibik
steckten und diese offshorbanken würden
dann den Zufluss in der Zentrale
einzahlen
zurück in die Vereinigten Staaten
transferierten konnten die USA den
Abfluss von Dollars stoppen
jedes Land achtet auf seine Devisenkurs
der Wechselkurs bezieht sich nicht nur
auf Importe und Exporte sondern auch auf
Kapitalbewegungen und wenn man sich die
monatlichen internationalen
finanzstatistiken des Internationalen
Währungsfonds anschaut hat man eine Art
stetige Handelsbilanz eine stetige
Einwanderung und Überweisungen und was
nach oben und unten geht nennt man
Fehler und Lücken was die Vereinten
Nationen und der IWF als Fehler und
Lücken bezeichnen ist fluchtkapital der
Grund für diese Lücken ist dass sie sich
damit nicht wirklich befassen wollen
in den 30er Jahren wollte Royal of Hall
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler im
US-Handelsministerium kriminelle
Bewegungen in die
zahlungsbilanzstatistik aufnehmen
der Kongress war sehr verärgert Mann
sagte mir in Washington das Argument sei
wir sind ein christliches Land wir
wollen keine Verbrechen melden
Mann verboten kriminelles Geld in die
Zahlungsbilanz aufzunehmen ich glaube
heute nennt man das Fehler und Lippen
man nennt es nicht mehr Kriminelle zu
und Abflüsse
in den 60er und 70er Jahren stand
Großbritannien vor einem ähnlichen
Dilemma wie die Vereinigten Staaten das
Geld floss ab und dadurch Sankt der Wert
des Pfunds
Großbritannien erkannte dass es den Wert
seiner Währung stützen konnte indem es
seinen Inlandsmarkt für die Billionen
von Dollars öffnete die durch seine
offshore helfen flossen aber genau wie
in dem Vereinigten Staaten hatte dies
einen unerwarteten
Nebeneffekten stecken heute genau wie im
19 Jahrhundert ihr Geld nicht in die
britische Produktion sondern in
Immobilienspekulationen in
Finanzspekulationen und in den
Devisenhandel die Finanzialisierung
Londons hat also zur die
Industrialisierung des Landes
beigetragen denn sie hat es ermöglicht
dass der Stirling durch diesen riesigen
Zustrom von heißem Geld gestürzt wird
diesen Zustrom von Geld aus dem
Drogenhandel von Kriminellen Geld und
Geld aus der Steuerhinterziehung in der
ganzen Welt das nach London fließt
anstatt in die Schweiz nach
Liechtenstein oder in die Karibik
mit der stillschweigenden Unterstützung
der Vereinigten Staaten wuchsen die
britischen offshore-oasen rasch an und
schon bald entwickelte sich das
offshore-system zum dominierenden
internationalen Finanzmarkt der Welt nur
wenige wussten wie dieser Markt
funktionierte
1986 ging der Wirtschaftswissenschaftler
John Christensen ins Ausland um dies zu
untersuchen er bewarb sich um eine
Stelle in der Niederlassung einer der
größten
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften der
Welt in Jersey weil die Leute habe ich
in der sogenannten Unternehmens und
Treuhandverwaltung gearbeitet also im
Bereich offshore ich bin extra ins
Ausland gegangen um in diesem Bereich zu
arbeiten weil man dort mit den
Offshore-Gesellschaften den
mantelgesellschaften und den offshore
Trust zu tun hat und sie verwaltet auf
diese Weise konnte ich von der Arbeit in
einer großen globalen
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft aus
genau sehen was die Kunden
ich hatte vollständigen Zugang zu allen
kundenakten und im Laufe meiner Arbeit
bei die Leute Push habe ich über 100
Jahre offshore-kunden untersucht und das
habe ich gefunden es gab einige
insider-händler einige Markt
Manipulationen einige die die
Offenlegung von Interessenkonflikten
vermieten
illegalen Waffenhandel illegaler
politischer Wahlkampfspenden
Schmiergelder Bestechung betrügerische
Rechnungsstellung falsche
Preisgestaltung im Handel und
Steuerhinterziehung haben
[Musik]
auf der Grundlage einer Stichprobe der
Kunden die ich mir angesehen habe war
kein einziger Kunde in etwas verwickelt
was ich als wirklich legitimer Aktivität
ansehen würde sie waren alle in
irgendeiner Art von Steuerhinterziehung
oder Schlimmeres verwickelt
ich habe mich mit Karl livin getroffen
er war früher ein amerikanischer Senator
und er hat sich eingehend über das
Private Banking erkundigt
er fragte die Banker was glauben Sie wie
hoch ist der Prozentsatz der Kunden die
diese Unternehmen für legitime Zwecke
nutzen
ich glaube dass
99,9% meiner Kunden diese Unternehmen
für illegale Zwecke nutzen
dass es reality das ist die Realität das
sind amerikanische Banker die erzählen
was sie tun und genau dasselbe gilt für
britische Banker die ihren Kunden helfen
konnten in Panama oder auf den Bermudas
oder den britischen kaimern-inseln zu
haben
[Musik]
geheimhaltungsrechtssprechung wird in
hohem Maße für betrügerische
Finanzaktivitäten und Grauzonen genutzt
Bereiche in denen die Geheimhaltung
nicht nur wünschenswert sondern eine
Notwendigkeit ist
legitime Finanzaktivitäten brauchen
weder die Geheimhaltung die
offshore-oasen bieten noch wollen sie
die hohen Gebühren zahlen die offshore
Banken und Anwaltskanzleien verlangen
[Musik]
heute sind fast die Hälfte der geheimen
Gerichtsbarkeiten der Welt britische
Dependenzen
in der Öffentlichkeit behaupten diese
Länder sie seien transparent und ihre
Finanzdienstleistung Sektoren sei mit
legitimen Finanzaktivitäten beschäftigt
unsere Wirtschaft basiert nicht auf
Geheimhaltung sie basiert auf
Transparenz sie basiert auf einem
soliden regulatorischen Umfeld sie
basiert auf guter Regierungsführung und
guter Regierung mit einem Rechtssystem
der britischen Regierung
darauf basieren unsere Finanzinstitute
wir haben nun eine Antwort von der
Finanzbehörde der Kaiman-Inseln nachdem
eine Gruppe von us-aktivisten
angekündigt hat herzukommen um auf die
ihrer Meinung nach bestehende
Steuerhinterziehung von Unternehmen
aufmerksam zu machen der Vorsitzende des
Finanzministeriums Richard Kohl ermutigt
die Gruppe zu einem Besuch und sagt der
Sektor habe nichts zu verbergen
ich würde sagen wenn jemand nach Cayman
kommen will um herauszufinden was wir
hier tun dann soll er kommen wir haben
hier keine Geheimnisse
2008 auf die Cayman Inseln kamen rief
ich den Regierungssprecher an oder sagte
wir haben eine Anweisung von ganz oben
dass niemand mit ihnen sprechen darf sie
sind tabu auf limits
im Jahr 2011 veröffentlichte der
Journalist Nicolas Jackson treasure
Islands ein bahnbrechendes Buch über das
offshore-system der Autor
internationaler Medienberichte sagt er
würde sich über ein Gespräch mit dem
Vorsitzenden der Cayman finance
Jackson kürzlich einen Schwachkopf mit
dem Verständnis eines elfjährigen
es wird immer eine Politik des Neides
geben jetzt wird die Politik des Neides
durch Schwachköpfe verschärft die nicht
wirklich verstehen was auf den Cayman
Inseln vor sich geht ich weiß nicht
wovon er redet und er weiß auch nicht
wovon er redet
die kaymann-inseln sind der fünf größte
Finanzplatz der Welt
sie beherbergen 80.000 registrierte
Unternehmen mehr als 3/4 der weltweiten
hätte Chance und 1,9 Billionen Dollar an
einladen die Einwohnerzahl beträgt
60.000 was in etwa der Zahl der
Obdachlosen in New York entspricht
die offshore-welt wird von einer
seltsamen Mischung von Charakteren
bevölkert britische Ex-Schüler
Mitglieder der Geheimdienste der Welt
globale kriminelle verschiedene Herren
und Damen und Bänker in Hülle und Fülle
dafür so viele reiche und mächtige
Personen so viel auf dem Spiel steht ist
es nicht verwunderlich das
Großbritanniens offshore helfen ihre
eigenen seltsamen Mechanismen entwickelt
haben um zu verhindern dass
Informationen nach außen dringend
für viele Menschen die im Ausland
arbeiten und denen nicht gefällt was sie
tun ist es in der Tat sehr schwer eine
andere Meinung zu vertreten denn sie
werden persönlich mit einem Grad an
Bösartigkeit angegriffen der ziemlich
außergewöhnlich ist meistens sind die
Instrumente der Unterdrückung relativ
raffiniert du wirst nicht befördert wenn
du das tust deine Familie wird es nicht
mögen
es geht nicht darum sie ins Gefängnis zu
stecken das ist viel zu blond wir reden
hier über das Establishment in diesen
Fällen das britische ist Tablet und die
Mechanismen sind sehr sehr subtil eine
Art von
Ächtung zum Beispiel
diese seltsamen Mechanismen wenn jemand
versucht die Sache zu verraten da gibt
es alle möglichen Methoden man feuert
sie nicht einfach man gibt ihnen viel zu
viel Arbeit man denkt sie in eine andere
Richtung
jemand der sehr gut weiß wie
Unterdrückung im Ausland funktioniert
ist der ehemaliger Gesundheitsminister
von Jersey Stuart Segway 2009 ließ er
einen Bericht über eine Krankenschwester
durchsickern die verdächtigt wurde
Patienten in einem Krankenhaus
umgebracht zu haben
am 10 März spitzte sich die
Angelegenheit während einer
Parlamentsdebatte zu Senator Segway
behauptete Senator jimmyard habe ihn
beschimpft und gesagt er solle sich
selbst Köpfen gehen
pauschardt wie ist die Behauptung zurück
aber weniger als eine Woche später
musste er zugeben dass er gelogen hatte
er räumte ein dass er Senator silvery
bei anderer Gelegenheit gesagt habe er
solle sich die Pulsadern aufschneiden
und damit allen einen Gefallen tun
ich wurde eines Morgens in meinem Haus
von sechs Polizeibeamten in Zivil
verhaftet da waren noch zwei
Spezialisten Polizeibeamte für die
Datensuche und zwei weitere
Polizeibeamte in ganzkörper Panzerung
mit einem dieser Rammböcke die sie bei
drogenrazien Einsetzen
zehn Polizisten stürmten also ohne
Durchsuchungsbefehl auf mich zu die
Wohnung wurde von oben bis unten
durchsucht alle Computer beschlagnahmt
und sie Stein mir alle möglichen
privaten wahlkreisdaten
kurz nachdem wir mit den Dreharbeiten
begonnen hatten verließ einen
Polizeibeamter das Revier im
Vorbeilaufen grinste er in die Kamera
der Beamte wollte die Sirenen an seine
Motorrad testen was er während des
restlichen Interviews in regelmäßigen
Abständen Tat als es darum ging mich zu
belangen
wurde nach dem Datenschutz gesetzt
als die Behörden mich strafrechtlich
verfolgten sagte ich dies sei eine
legitime Verteidigung im öffentlichen
Interesse zusammen mit einem
Sachverständigen legte ich eine Reihe
von Berichten vor die den Fall der
Staatsanwaltschaft effektiv zerstörten
[Musik]
als Reaktion darauf entschieden die
Richter das verteidigungssache er habe
den Bericht im öffentlichen Interesse
weitergegeben nicht mehr zulässig sein
trotzdem verfolgten sie ihn weiter ohne
eine Verteidigung in den vergangenen
sieben Jahren wurde Severin wiederholt
vor Gericht gestellt und dreimal
inhaftiert
er weiß nicht ob und wann die Verfolgung
enden wird und er weiß auch nicht wann
er wieder hinter Gittern landen wird
wenn man Jersey von außen betrachtet
sieht es so aus als gäbe es ein
strafverfolgungssystem ein Gericht und
eine Legislative aber nichts davon ist
real es ist ein potenzdorf sein ist
dieser Systeme sehr erfüllt die
Anforderungen objektiv zu sein
objektiv zu sein oder tatsächlich
richtig zu funktionieren
die Erfahrung die stürzt hat liegt
vielleicht am unteren Ende der Skala er
wurde einfach unterdrückt und wegen
erfundener Anschuldigungen vor Gericht
gestellt
[Musik]
lassen Sie uns das Interview fortsetzen
vielleicht langweilen die sich
irgendwann
[Musik]
so läuft die Unterdrückung in Jersey es
werden alle möglichen kleinen Dinge
getan um Leute zu schikanieren sie gehen
nicht oft zu solchen extremen über wie
sie es gegen mich getan haben indem sie
mich tatsächlich verhaften und ins
Gefängnis stecken die Behörden wenden
alle möglichen anderen Methoden an Leute
zu behindern Dinge zu sabotieren und den
Leuten das Leben schwer zu machen
wenn du das das Tablet in Jersey
verärgerst wirst du hier keinen Job
bekommen deine Kinder werden keine
anständigen Jobs bekommen so ungefähr
funktioniert das
ich war im März 2009 mit Nick Jackson
and Jersey etwa 24 Stunden nach unserer
Ankunft in Jersey wir waren mehrere Tage
dort sagte Nick was du bemerkt dass wir
verfolgt werden seit wir am Flughafen
angekommen sind werden wir verfolgt
schau jetzt nicht hin aber wir werden
verfolgt
es stellte sich heraus dass er Recht
hatte wir wurden verfolgt und das fand
ich beunruhigend sehr beunruhigend sogar
es gibt ein Sprichwort in Jersey wenn es
dir hier nicht gefällt gibt es morgens
immer ein Boot
in der Werbebroschüre von Jersey finance
heißt es Jersey ist eine Erweiterung der
City
das ist der Ort an dem die City of
London viele der Aktivitäten durchführt
die sehen London selbst nicht
durchführen könnte
wir sind hier um über diese Firma namens
applebee zu sprechen ich werde einfach
vorlesen was Sie auf Ihrer Webseite
sagen Mitarbeiter von applebi haben es
nicht nur in politischer Ämter geschafft
sondern inzentren wie den Bermudas
Jersey der Isle of Man und den
kaymann-inseln in hohe richterliche
Ämter sie rühmen sich also damit es Ihre
Mitarbeiter einen Austausch mit den
Leuten haben die in diesen offshore
Finanzzentren an der Macht sind
dieselben Anwälte und Buchhalter die
offshore-trusts einrichten und verwalten
sind auch in hohen politischen
Positionen tätig in Großbritanniens auf
Vorwelt sind die meisten Politiker in
der Wirtschaft tätig sie betreiben
Lobbyarbeit für die Wirtschaft und
fördern deren Interessen sie entwerfen
verfeinern und verabschieden Gesetze
Politiker sitzen in den Vorständen der
Unternehmen die sie eigentlich
regulieren sollen
es gibt keinen Platz für schmutziges
Geld in Großbritannien in der Tat sollte
es nirgendwo einen Platz für schmutziges
Geld geben die Herausforderung die ich
heute an jedes Land Stelle besteht darin
die Korruption auszurotten Transparenz
darüber zu gewährleisten was ihre
eigenen Unternehmen tun und Transparenz
auch für ausländische Unternehmen in
ihrem Land zu verlangen und mit uns
zusammen zu arbeiten um diesen Ansatz
der Transparenz auf der ganzen Welt zu
verbreiten
in der Öffentlichkeit behaupten
britische Politiker sie würden gegen
Geheimhaltungsvorschriften und
Korruption vorgehen aber in der Praxis
tun sie das Gegenteil
wenn ich mit Politikern in Brüssel
Sprecher sagen sie das mehr Lobbyisten
aus London auch Politiker zu ihnen
gekommen sind um die Interessen der City
of London zu schützen als aus allen
anderen europäischen Mitgliedsstaaten
zusammen das gibt Ihnen eine Vorstellung
davon in welchem Ausmaß britische
Politiker sich im Wesentlichen als
Lobbyisten für die City of London sehen
beginnen mit unserer großen Geschichte
die Bemühungen der kaymann-inseln um
Transparenz im
Finanzdienstleistungssektor werden von
der internationalen Gemeinschaft
anerkannt der britische Premierminister
Cameron erklärte den Parlament das
Etikett Steueroase das den
kronbesitzungen und Überseegebieten
angeheftet wird sei unfair
viele britische Politiker haben
persönliche und geschäftliche
Verbindungen zur City of London und zu
britischen Steueroasen der Vater des
ehemaligen britischen Premierministers
David Cameron ihren Cameron war ein
Experte für off-fonds und war seit den
80er Jahren an offshore Trusts beteiligt
in diesem Gerichtsgebäude hier in San
Helia haben wir dies gefunden es ist ein
Dokument das sich Testaments
vollstreckerzeugnis nennt und zum
Testament von niemand anderem als ihren
Cameron gehört David Cameron Vater
[Applaus]
in war sicherlich ein wohlhabender Mann
2009 wurde sein persönliches Vermögen in
der Sunday Times rich List auf 10
Millionen Punkte geschätzt doch als er
2010 starb war sein Nachlass viel
kleiner als erwartet nämlich nur 2,7
Millionen Pfund
in vielen Fällen sind es die Politiker
und die ihre Busenfreunde Familien und
so weiter und die Geschäftsleute die die
Parteien sponsern die diese
offshore-dienste nutzen sie haben also
kein persönliches Interesse daran sie zu
schließen wenn Sie das tun wollten
könnten sie es morgen tun tatsache ist
dass er es nicht wollen weil sie selbst
darin verwickelt sind
wenn man aus dem gleichen Milieu kommt
und die richtige Leute kennt fallen alle
juristischen Feinheiten oft weg man kann
alle möglichen Dinge tun die man nicht
einfach so tun würde wenn man an die Tür
klopft und fragt ob man eine Offshore
Firma gründen kann um dies zu tun wird
man zum Teufel gejagt aber wenn man Teil
des Netzwerks ist kann man solche Dinge
tun das ist ein sehr wichtiger Teil des
ganzen Systems dieses britisches Tablet
mit der Oberschicht dass er schon seit
Jahrhunderten gibt
das britische ist ein altes Netzwerk
privilegierter Eliten hatte sich nach
dem Untergang des Empire eine lukrative
Nische in der offshore-welt geschaffen
sie wandelten sich von Verwaltern des
Empire zu finanzverwaltern für die
globale Elite und multinationale
Konzerne
je mehr Geld ins Ausland floss desto
mehr bekamen die Gesellschaften rund um
den Globus die Auswirkungen der
offshorwelt zu spüren
in Wirklichkeit ist es nicht so wie Sie
denken dass ihr Premierminister die
Macht hat über die Zukunft ihres Landes
zu entscheiden
die Macht ist hier versteckt
es gibt immer mehr Länder auf der Welt
in denen der Mangel an finanzieller
Transparenz bei der Besteuerung bei den
Eigentumsverhältnissen und bei der
Korruption das Ausmaß untergräbt indem
die Regierungen repräsentative
politische Entscheidungen für ihre
Bürger treffen wir haben extrem Fälle
wie die versteckte Steuerhinterziehung
durch Leute in den Finanzministerien in
Griechenland in Frankreich aber wir
haben auch dieses System das im
Allgemeinen auf anonymen Firmenbesitz
ausgerichtet ist den anonymen Besitz von
Immobilien in ganz London in halb
Schottland
glauben wir wirklich das Regierungen
besser funktionieren dass die Märkte
besser funktionieren dass die Verteilung
von Einkommen und Vermögen besser ist
wenn wir zulassen dass so viel verborgen
bleibt
wer will denn nicht wissen mit wem man
Geschäfte macht wer möchte dass seine
Regierung von Leuten geführt wird deren
Vermögen versteckt ist deren
Finanztransaktionen anonym im Ausland
abgewickelt werden
das ist eine schlechte Rechnung für die
Welt
die Bürger müssen verstehen was passiert
dass sie die Last tragen und dass ich
einige mächtige Personen von der
Steuerpflicht befreien
die einfachen Leute zahlen Steuern die
Reichen nicht
das ist Ungleichheit und führt zu
Populismus denn es zeigt so deutlich
dass die Menschen die heute an der
Spitze der Welt stehen nicht in der Lage
sind sich um die Interessen der
einfachen Leute zu kümmern
damals in den 60er und 70er Jahren wurde
Steuerhinterziehung oder der Widerstand
gegen die Besteuerung als etwas
angesehen das gegen das Establishment
gerichtet war sie wissen schon die
Rolling Stones und Phil Collins all
diese Leute die ins Ausland abwandern
verschwinden das wurde als eine Art
Rebellion angesehen und wenn man in die
heutige Zeit vorspult dann ist das jetzt
das Tablet das offshore-system ist das
Establishment offshore ist heute die Art
und Weise die Eliten und multinationale
Konzerne ihre Geschäfte abwickeln
steuerhinterziehung ist die Art und
Weise die Geschäfte gemacht werden
diese Art von raffiniertem betrug
erfordert eine riesige Infrastruktur wir
sprechen gerne von der Nadelstreifen
Infrastruktur hochgebildeter Menschen
die meinen es sei ihr Recht anderen zu
helfen die Gesellschaft zu betrügen
[Musik]
wir haben eine neue Mafia in der Stadt
sie schießt nicht wirklich auf Menschen
sie schießt ihn dann keine Kugeln in die
Kniescheiben aber ihr Handel ist genauso
tödlich sie beraubt die Menschen der
Möglichkeit
Gesundheitsversorgung Bildung Sicherheit
Gerechtigkeit und im Grunde ein
erfülltes Leben zu haben
Buchhalter bilden das Rückgrat des
offshore-systems sie verwalten die
Strukturen die es Einzelpersonen und
Unternehmen ermöglichen ihr Geld ins
Ausland zu verschieben und Steuern zu
hinterziehen
es gibt etwa 2,5 Millionen professionell
qualifizierte Buchhalter auf diesem
Planeten etwa 330.000 davon in
Großbritannien
bekannte Leute gut gekleidet gut
gefüttert hoch bezahlt sitzen in ihren
Büros im Stadtzentrum und werden dafür
bezahlt sich steuervermeidungsprogramme
für Privatleute und Unternehmen
auszudenken
wir können alle eine Regierung wählen
die sagt fehlt uns wir geben euch eine
bessere Gesundheitsversorgung Bildung
und Sicherheit und am nächsten Tag sagt
der Buchhalter tut mir leid leute ihr
habt diese Regierung gewählt aber wir
haben einen steuervermeidungsprogramm
und die Amazons und Google ist im
Microsoft werden hier keine Steuern
zahlen schade ihr habt dafür gestimmt
aber ihr bekommt etwas anderes
das ist eine verrückte Welt das ein Teil
des Geschäftsmodells der großen
wirtschaftsprüfungsfirmen darin besteht
der Öffentlichkeit Dienstleistungen zu
verweigern indem man die Steuereinnahmen
auswählt und diese Firmen werden dann
mit staatlich finanzierten Verträgen
belohnt und dieselben Firmen beraten
dann die Regierungen und dieselben
Firmen berichten dann über die
unternehmensabschlüsse und sagen uns
dass alles gut ist
als ich mit einem Partner vom Preis
Waterhouse darüber sprach sagte er
Professor sicker sie sollten das mehr
anerkennen wie erwirtschaften Millionen
von Dollar an Einnahmen und wir haben
viele viele zufriedene Kunden was ist
ihr Problem und meine Antwort war ganz
einfach das ist die Sprache von
Drogenhändlern und Zuhältern
[Musik]
in Großbritannien stieg eine neue Art
von Beamten an die Spitze auf
einer dieser Beamten war Dave hartnet
der an die Spitze des agmrc der
britischen Steuerbehörde Aufstieg
Dave hartnet hatte eine neue Art der
Steuererhebung Geschäfte wurden auf
individueller basis- und hinter
verschlossenen Türen ausgehandelt
bei den größten Kunden führte hartnet
die Verhandlungen häufig selbst
Telekom war eines der ersten Unternehmen
dass das Programm durchlief und eine
Rückerstattung von über einer Milliarde
Pfund erhielt der Vorstandsvorsitzende
von BT
schrieb der Gewinn pro Aktie ist um 14%
gestiegen und es ist schön zu wissen
dass wir eine Gutschrift von einer
Milliarde Pfund vom Finanzamt erhalten
haben Dave behauptete dieser Ansatz sei
effizienter
Rechtsstreitigkeiten vor den Gerichten
sind in der heutigen Zeit überall auf
der Welt wirklich phänomenal teuer und
ich denke man sollte sie nach
Möglichkeit vermeiden die Kunst besteht
darin die Leute durch starke Argumente
und ähnliches zur Zahlung zu bewegen
nach dem Ausbruch der Proteste im Jahr
2011 befragte ein Sonderausschuss des
Finanzministeriums stefannet hartnet
behauptete er könne aufgrund des
steuerzahlergeheimnisses keine Auskunft
geben
welche gesetzlichen Bestimmungen hindern
sie daran den Parlament Informationen zu
geben
alles was ich bisher gesagt habe Herr
bakli war dass ich und meine Kollegen
durch das Gesetz und die Entscheidung
der Kommissare daran gehindert werden
was Dave nicht erwähnte die
Rechtsberatung die erhalten hatte besagt
dass die Offenlegung von Informationen
im Ermessen des Chefs des ajmac der Chef
des elternasie
so wie die Mafia in den Staat
eingedrungen ist sind auch die
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften in den
Staat eingedrungen der Leiter der
Abteilung für Steuervermeidung in der
britischen Steuerbehörde kommt aus einer
dieser Firmen der neue nannte
Vorsitzende von per majestys revenue
customs einer Steuerbehörde ist ein
Partner von KPG ihre Partner sind in den
Staat eingedrungen sie leiten das
Finanzministerium
die britische finanzleistungsindustrie
war in den Staat eingedrungen und begann
die Gesetze zu ihrem eigenen Vorteil zu
gestalten
auf das Ausmaß der politischen
Vereinnahmung durch die City of London
durch die großen Banken und die großen
Anwaltskanzleien ist so enorm dass die
Politiker praktisch zu deren
sprachrohren geworden sind
da die Regierung nicht bereit ist im
Interesse der Öffentlichkeit zu handeln
konfrontierte eine Gruppe von
Demonstranten Dave hartnet bei einer
privaten Veranstaltung in Oxford
er es tut uns leid sie zu stören wir
werden nur ein paar Augenblicke ihrer
Zeit in Anspruch nehmen wir sind heute
Abend hier um Dave eine Auszeichnung zu
überreichen den Preis für sein
Lebenswerk für seine Verdienste um die
Steuerplanung von Unternehmen
[Applaus]
ein großartiger Freund für viele von uns
im Laufe der Jahre wir können dir
wirklich nicht genug danken für das was
du getan hast
dadurch Milliarden an Steuern gespart
und auch unsere Freunde bei Goldman Sex
haben dadurch Millionen gesparty 25
Millionen diese Leute sind Eindringlinge
dies ist eine ungesetzliche Verschwörung
zum Hausfriedensbruch und sie werden
gehen sie werden sofort gehen bevor wir
die Hunde auf sie hetzen
gehen Sie das ist Hausfriedensbruch
gehen sie
nach seiner Pensionierung wechselte
David in die Privatwirtschaft unter
anderem zu
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft die
Leute wo er ausländische Regierungen in
Sachen Unternehmensbesteuerung bereit
dave ist Mitglied eines britischen
Ritterordens eine Auszeichnung die ihm
von der britischen Monarchin verliehen
wurde
es gibt ehemalige Minister die als
Berater für
Wirtschaftsprüfungsunternehmen tätig
sind
Wirtschaftsprüfungsunternehmen bieten
potenziellen Ministern Arbeitsplätze und
Beratungsdienste an meiner Meinung nach
ist das eine Hinweis auf korrupte
Strukturen man kauft und verkauft
Einfluss wenn ein ehemaliger Minister
für eine Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft
arbeitet vermittelt er kein
buchhaltungswissen eröffnet politische
Möglichkeiten im In- und Ausland das ist
das was sie tun
ich hoffe dass sie es inzwischen sehen
wie ich ich traue den meisten Bankern
nicht den meisten Anwälten und
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften ich
glaube dass sie sich in einer
Verschwörung gegen das öffentliche
Interesse befinden
in Großbritannien tragen Geheimhaltung
und Komplexität im Finanzwesen und in
der Regierung dazu bei Korruption in
öffentlichem Ämtern zu verschleiern die
Finanzstrukturen sind oft so komplex
dass sie selbst dann wenn sie öffentlich
aufgedeckt werden nicht als das erkannt
werden was sie sind ein Beispiel dafür
ist PFI die private finance
dabei handelt es sich um eine Methode
zur Finanzierung öffentlicher
Infrastrukturen wie Krankenhäuser
Schulen Straßen und Brücken die aber
über den privaten Sektor und nicht wie
bisher über die Zentralregierung
finanziert werden über eine Zeitraum von
30 oder 40 Jahren sind die
rückzahlungskosten insgesamt drei oder
viermal höher als wenn man sich das Geld
von der Zentralregierung leid es handelt
sich also im Grunde um einen
gigantischen buchhaltungsbetrug
sobald Politik eingeführt war stellte
man fest dass die vier großen
wirtschaftsprüfungsfirmen eigentlich
bezahlte Mitarbeiter des
Finanzministeriums waren die dann
tatsächlich herumliefen und für die
Umsetzung von pierfrei Verträgen durch
öffentliche Behörden sollten teilen
Effekte nicht sein sie sagten komm zu
uns und wir werden euch zeigen wie ihr
den größten Nutzen daraus ziehen könnt
mit anderen Worten wie man die
Gesetzgebung vielleicht ausnutzen kann
even the office sogar die Büros der
staatlichen Steuerbehörde sind jetzt im
Ausland angesiedelt die age of Merc die
Steuerbehörde hier in Großbritannien hat
ihre Büros auf den Bermudas und gehört
einer Firma namens mapley steps das ist
ziemlich unglaublich
das Unternehmen das den pffi-vertrag für
den Betrieb des hmacy hauptbüros besitzt
hat sich bei offshore Investoren Geld zu
15% Zinsen geliehen
da die Zinsen so hoch waren machte das
Unternehmen Verluste und zahlte daher
keine Steuern
im Jahr 2011
nicht nachweisen dass irgendein
pfei-unternehmen im Vereinigten
Königreich Steuern bezahlt hat
ich glaube wir müssen eine ernsthafte
Diskussion über die Rolle der Regierung
in diesen ganzen Debakel führen und
darüber wie sehr die Regierungen von
großen Banken und
Wirtschaftsprüfungsunternehmen
unterwandert wurden und in wessen
Interesse sie letztendlich handeln
Africa Public Private Partnership
conference
London 2015
der Grund für unseren Protest vor der
Africa ppp-konferenz war dass wir
sicherstellen wollten dass die Bürger in
Afrika davon erfahren dass diese Politik
hier im Vereinigten Königreich ein
kompletter Fehlschlag war wir wissen
dass diese Produkte in den afrikanischen
Ländern nicht in Ihrem eigenen Interesse
vermarktet werden die einzige Motivation
besteht darin die Reichweite von
Finanzdienstleistungen auf neue Märkte
auszudehnen das alles wird im Interesse
der Londoner City geführt was wir hier
leben ist im Grunde eine zweite Form der
Kolonialisierung zunächst gab es eine
Besetzung und Ressourcengewinnung und
durch diesen Prozess haben Länder wie
Großbritannien die ein großes offshore
Imperium hatten bedeutende Netzwerke
entwickelt und jetzt werden diese
Netzwerke genutzt um
Finanzdienstleistungen zu fördern und
auszubeuten
die City of London war das schlagende
finanzielle Herz des britischen Empire
als das Empire unterging wandelte sich
die City von einer Drehscheibe der
finanzmaschinerie des Empire Empire zu
einem globalen Finanzzentrum
ehemals unbedeutende Außenposten des
Empire wurden zur Grundlage eines
Spinnennetzes von geheimen offshore
Rechtssystemen die den Reichtum aus der
ganzen Welt einfingen und in die City of
London leiteten heute werden 25% der
internationalen Finanzgeschäfte auf
britischem Territorium abgewickelt fast
die Hälfte aller geheimen Rechtssysteme
weltweit steht unter britischem Schutz
und etwa die Hälfte des
offshorevermögens könnte in den
britischen offshore helfen versteckt
sein
im Bereich der Finanzdienstleistungen
verdienen Großbritanniens Eliten ihr
Geld und hier finden auch ehemalige
regierungsminister hohe Beamte und
pensionierte Spione des my5 und MSX nach
ihrer Zeit im öffentlichen Dienst
lukrative Berater stellen
gemeinsam haben sie Großbritannien und
seine Dependenzen in die größte
Steueroase der Welt verwandelt was der
Entwicklung in der ganzen Welt schadet
und Großbritannien selbst in ein Land
verwandelt das vor allem den Interessen
seiner Eliten dient
[Musik]
die Abschaffung von Steueroasen und
finanzgeheimnissen ist nicht unmöglich
hier sind fünf Schritte um Ihnen ein
Ende zu setzen
verhindern dass öffentliche Verwaltungen
Aufträge an Unternehmen vergeben die in
Steuerparadiesen tätig sind erstellen
öffentlicher Verzeichnisse der
wirtschaftlichen Eigentümer von
Unternehmen Treuhandgesellschaften und
Stiftungen Einführung vollständiger
Transparenz bei Geschäften und geheimen
Vereinbarungen zwischen Unternehmen und
Regierungen Einführung einer
öffentlichen länderbezogenen
Berichterstattung durch multinationale
Unternehmen Einführung eines
automatischen
Informationsaustausch zwischen allen
Ländern
[Musik]